[Music]
hello LAN it looks like he and Landon
something happens there between them
something's been happening of course and
now it's just she's got her you know
moment to uh move in I'm a flower you
had drinks with her the night out of the
night of or after so um and I've rolled
off
Naomi texted me and I literally was
laying on our couch and rolled onto the
floor laughing like a little kid like
this on the floor big like no way no way
no way I I will give everything away so
I'm just not gonna say okay I'm like
that kind of person I either say it all
or nothing it's ah yeah I don't think I
don't know man this girl yeah she is
your soul mate
what fascinating yeah what happens this
year it's not you know under a veil of
secrecy okay it's you get to see Landon
and Thomas can I say I think some things
come out that explain maybe past
behaviors and but pretty interest
instead of us having to try and figure
out what happens you get to watch just
watch it on guys yeah yeah with shame I
was I had no idea what's gonna happen
yeah well I'm just gonna take a chance
let's give it a shot Oh maybe they found
their equals and that's fine letting me
cake well I guess people just have to
wait and see
[Music]
you